tag nine
bootleg cav boy
um you are getting to a point man where
it's like
i feel like it's like getting hard to
outdo yourself every album you you you
know like this last album you
have you know you accomplish a couple
things you you got you know system of
down on the surge on the album which is
something that you've always wanted yes
and you got the door the doors which is
the inspiration behind the name of the
label oh yes it is
so you you keep like kind of one-upping
yourself yeah um i want to know like
is
when
are you gonna stop like when you're
gonna kick back and maybe take a year or
two off like it's this is just non-stop
what you like now you put out the
therapy joint like it's not time man uh
i paid the irs a lot of money it ain't
time yet
he said it ain't time
yeah you know i paid a lot the irs a lot
of money you know and so i need to get
it back yeah
i still got it but it's like i need more
you know i'm saying i got a lot of
people got to take care of i got a lot
of i got a lot of things you know sammy
and travis so
we're um going up again you know what i
mean and when it comes to music
um i just said some real stuff to you i
don't know if you caught it but i just
said some real stuff but um
when it comes to music
i can only get better it's other people
i want to work with it's like i've been
able to just been talking to what we got
to do the eminem clap you got to do that
i've been trying to do eminem for a long
time
and a lot we do have but um it takes a
lot of time and i'm i'm the kind of guy
that writes on the spot right there when
i feel a beat and i record it then i
send it to somebody and i expect it back
in a couple days or maybe a week right
i'm saying not everyone's got this paul
rosenberg says six months i'm like you
know what we do in six month money you
know what i'm saying i put out an album
and an ep
you know it's not too many songs i can
just send eminem i'm not just trying to
get eminem on something just to get his
name on my album i don't care about
names because names do not sell albums
100 you know what i mean i got ceelo
green on my last album i got serge
tonkin on my last album i got game i got
big crit i got it
uh uh i got a t-pain who else i got i
got so many people man the doors it
doesn't mean that
all their millions of fans are going to
buy my album i do music because i love
these people's music and what they do
they're crabs i had lil wayne on my last
album and kendrick lamar on my last
album i got kendrick lamar on this new
album
still that doesn't mean that your album
is going to be all their fans are going
to buy your album i do music because i
love these people's artistry so with
that being said
um saying that futures don't really sell
your album you know what i mean and
that's the realness of it um
i'm gonna keep doing music with the
people that i love to do music with
that'd be organic yeah yeah yeah yeah so
um me and uh citizen cope you know
saying clarence greenwood you know said
we've been talking for a while you know
i'm sizzling um me and kylie budd's been
talking for a while you know what i mean
um it's been talk of uh
uh
a metallica thing you know what i'm
saying okay we'll see we'll see all
right i know you're a big ross fan i
think that'd be interesting oh yeah yeah
ross i i just i just want to get ross on
something rock-ish i want to take ross
out of his uh element that'd be dope you
know i don't want to do something that
sounds like ross you know i'm saying
everybody does something that sounds
like ross 100 so if ross comes into
strange land i'ma put something on him
i'm gonna put something on him that he
can um
talk about because i know he has
knowledge i hear it in his music i know
he has knowledge i know he reads i know
he has knowledge you know what i'm
saying so um
and it could be about chicks i don't
know it might be something about chicks
it could be about anything whatever the
music will say that's what i'll get ross
on you know what i mean but i'm i'm
going to wait for that to come you know
um they say do another worldwide
choppers after that last worldwide
choppers with me twist the busta rhymes
and
uh uh yellow wolf and just everybody
else i had on the song it going to be
hard to top that
so only way you can top that is get
eminem on the worldwide choppers and
jay-z maybe to do his um you know choppy
bring it back dude
you know what i'm saying and um some
other cats from all over the world last
time i had people from turkey everywhere
yeah mark and you know what i mean so i
just i just gotta wait it's hard being
tech9 man because i'm actually trying to
be better than everything i do and
that's hard to do 100 i mean it's the
goal like eventually like let's say 15
years from now
you probably 15 years from now man i'm
gonna be i'm gonna i'm gonna buy an
island and you'll be chilling i'll buy a
piece of fiji or something man okay
let's let's say let's say in five years
like years let's say from five years
from now
uh
you know
do you do you ever see it being where
where
tech isn't the biggest artist on strange
maybe you find somebody you know i hope
i find that
big artist every day you know what i'm
saying and i found him already you know
i'm saying chris calico is right there
oh 100 percent you know i mean he's
doing this
crew is right there you know what i mean
all my artists jay rock is right there
you know what i'm saying so all my
artists are elite and able to be even
bigger than me that's what i go for
that's why you signed up that's why i
signed them so it's like
um
five years from now
you know i'm ready to kick it man you
know i'm ready to kick it man
you know what i'm saying i'm ready to go
if system up and down is planned and
turkey i want to go if slipknot is
playing in germany i want to go if uh r
kelly and snoop's playing on the boat i
want to go you know i'm going to take
somebody i can sit on my face and go man
you know what i'm saying and it's like
i want to party man
i just i just told some chick the other
night i was some bad [__] i ran into
okay i said hey man as long as i got a
face you got a place to sit
exactly
so i just i just want to go be the fan
chris calico said nah man i want to be
the man i said i am the man i want to be
the fan i want to go to shows and and
kick it and eat and drink and be married
for tomorrow you may die 100 man do you
think that um i always like if you were
to ask me man like
like in my personal top 10 of all time
like you're definitely like
there like you know what i mean i i feel
like you're historically underrated
because
you know i mean the whole thing with
tech9 that's been beat over the head so
much is that a lot of people are scared
to listen to or like look at you as like
you know
you know the guy with the face pain they
don't [__] with you or they you know
they won't even they won't even visit
the music based on that exactly but like
do you feel like like when you think
like [__] man like all the records you
sold the quality of music you've been
making for all these years and the fact
in my opinion you're the greatest
performer in hip-hop history we're
starting to we're starting to see that
um i mean where do you put your i know
it's a hard question but where do you
put yourself in the greatest of all time
i put myself
as elite
and one who tries to create
new things possibly new things because
the old heads say ain't nothing new
you're just recycling we we all have god
complexes and we think that we can
create something new
so i put myself at elite
and i put myself
you know i want to be normal you know
what i'm saying and i i've always been
abnormal in the brain or my thought
process has been abnormal i guess that's
what sets me aside but um
you know i just put me as an elite
artist man and i want to work with those
that are also elite man you know what
i'm saying i don't i don't i mean we
listen to music i listen to you i used
to be a dancer before i was a rapper you
know what i'm saying so i know it i'm a
stoner i'm a storm i'm a stoner i know
what that's for i'm a star you ain't
about to put that in the cipher you know
it's not there's people need to stop
hating them i hate the label [__] yeah
i'm like
people need to stop hating on cats and
let cats do what they know and do what
they love and if you do this other thing
don't say nothing about them cats over
there you know saying i never understood
the krs 1 and nelly thing you know what
i'm saying because they do two different
things yeah
i can't do the difference
saying something about soulja boy you
know what i'm saying it's like i never
understood
people hating on because everybody got
the idea of what hip-hop should be you
know i'm saying this is what i love
about hip-hop
okay if hip-hop is supposed to be
backpack what was happening in like the
90s or something you know i'm saying why
wasn't
the message backpack you know what i'm
saying why wasn't curtis blow
backpacking right people just this is
where they grew up this is when they
fell in love with it so you can't hate
them for that you know what i'm saying
they say that's real hip-hop
it started
with rap dirty you know what i'm saying
with blowfly and then it went to the
sugar hill gang dance music it's called
hip hop yep hip hop and that means you
dancing you know saying it started as
dance music so when did it become so
that ain't hip-hop that's what i don't
understand people just have to realize
that
it's different types of
music out here for you to enjoy yeah
like you can love what you love walk a
flocka you play a waka song and get a
reaction from the club yeah and you you
can't play like it's just exactly it
makes you know it's just kanye probably
grew up listening to um tribal quest and
stuff just like we did you know what i'm
saying but i grew up listening to
everything you know what i'm saying from
the gangster [__]
to you know what i'm saying the backpack
[__] you know what i'm saying i don't
know if i can cuss on here yeah
the knowledge of self [__] you know what
i'm saying whatever that's kind of you
know just whatever the rock and roll rap
[__] which run dmc started thanks to
rick rubin you know what i'm saying with
rock box and then the king of rock and
all that and uh walk this way you know
what i'm saying thank you for that run
dmc you know saying thank the beastie
boys for doing it as well you know what
i'm saying with no sleep to brooklyn and
[__] like that you know what i'm saying
you got to fight for your right to party
all that we listening to everything so
when people try to say this the real
hip-hop [__] that's just where you grew
up listening to it and falling in love
with it yeah i hate to listen what i'm
saying
thank you for me being right in the
middle in kansas city we're getting it
from everywhere [__] i was listening to
m c shot d i was listening to two live
crew you know what i'm saying throw that
d
d you know what i'm saying i was
listening to everything i was listening
to eric being rock him i was listening
to the bdp i fell in love with nwa and
public enemy music period straight up we
love it and i'm
a big baller all that [__] technology
the complete technique of rhyme all
right what's next uh you say you might
be working with metallica that'd be
crazy are you already working i mean on
a new album
i'm about to start seven's about to send
me um
seven is about to send me beats on these
on this uh
tour okay you know he said he's gonna
start last monday you know saying it's
called special effects
and um i name it that because
we already let everybody know that we're
the best at what we do when we musically
you know sense sonically yeah you know
what i'm saying so now it's time to play
with the music you know i'm saying
really still rap about real [__] but um
you know it's time to play with the
music play with the beat dj [__] with
the beat you know i'm saying it's like
um it's time to start playing with stuff
and getting you know me and excision
been talking you know what i'm saying so
it's time to start playing with music
you know
and um
i'm anxious to see what's going to come
after something else because something
else i was saying yes i have something
else other than what i've been doing all
these years yeah something else and i
told the truth
you know saying when you have a song
called so dope it has to be so dope yeah
if you have a song called hard off the
new album strange relation that's coming
out may 6 it has to be hard i'm gonna
keep on pressing
and i won't know what i'm gonna write
until the beats come you know what i'm
saying i'll write
what the beats tell me to write you know
what i'm saying perfect yeah well yo
tonight uh he's gonna be performing live
at the ritz
yeah yeah i don't know i just woke up
and came here man jaren benton i took a
shower though you know
freddie gibbs tech nine yeah and it's
like we're druggies man it's psych
wardrobe please if you have not seen
tech nine perform you'll be a fan after
you leave the show yeah man yeah yeah
yeah so let's come you know saying
you're guaranteed to see
uh bras done on stage and then you'll
areolas yeah areola's